i'm really delighted today to
introduce ting hui lau who is a newly
appointed
assistant professor of anthropology at
yale and u.s college
and i consider uh ting to be a friend
and colleague
i got to know ting a little bit during
my year
at the tail end of my year in singapore
when i was teaching as visiting
faculty at yale and u.s before she had
started her position there
um and so i'm really excited to know
that she's taking up the position there
because i think she's going to do
important things to complement
the already strong anthropology
department there
she recently received her phd in
anthropology from cornell
and she is already in the process of
finalizing a book manuscript
entitled wounds of progress colonial
development
and the politics of affliction on the
china-myanmar border
and the dissertation fieldwork which
informs the book
is built on a decade of engagement and
two years of continuous field work with
lisu
subsistence farmers and ting has earned
a reputation in southeast asian studies
for her tenacity as a field worker in
notoriously difficult
field environments colleagues i know
from cornell and others who know about
her work constantly rave about the
importance of her project
which rethinks the violent colonial
dimensions of development
which in this area instead of delivering
poverty reduction
has inadvertently perpetuated high rates
of violence
alcoholism disease and mental illness
which are interpreted by the lesso as
forms of haunting
curses in demon madness
really important and fascinating work by
a really important
rising new scholar in southeast asian
studies so
please join me in welcoming ting for the
talk today entitled
conjuring spirits the melancholic play
of alcohol drinking lesson men
on the china myanmar border good
afternoon everyone
and thank you so much eric for the very
kind introduction
um and thank you everybody for being
here it's such a great honor to have a
chance to share my work with the
southeast asian studies community in
yale
and i'm really extremely grateful for
the opportunity
today i will be sharing a chapter from
my book in progress
wounds of progress colonial development
and the politics of affliction
the book examines development and
affliction among indigenous lisu men
in the new river valley on the
china-myanma border
following a group of lisu men in their
struggle
with chronic pain alcoholism and madness
i examined the social and political
forces
that give rise to these afflictions as
well as the ways
that lisa regenerate from them
the chapter i will be talking about
today focuses on alcohol drinking
and what leads to term alcohol madness
jupiter
do you see my next slide
alcohol drinking gatherings are common
across lisu villages
in the new river valley these gatherings
last between a few hours and a week
during which the men do not work and
hardly eat
spending their nights and days drinking
role-playing
telling stories and singing they descend
into alcohol madness when thus possessed
the men are no longer authors of their
own words
but speak on behalf of the spirit me
straddling the space between the living
and the dead
the alcohol mad men haunt villagers with
their
[Music]
miniature speeches and uncanny cries for
the lost souls
of forgotten ancestors
this paper examines alcohol drinking as
a form of melancholic play
through which non-christian lisu men
refused indigenous cultural erasure
under chinese development and christian
missionarization
lisu in the valley have long had to
grapple with the dual colonial forces
of christian missionarization and
chinese state encroachment
christianity was introduced by foreign
missionaries in the early 20th century
while chinese state encroachment has
been ongoing for centuries
since the 1950s both these ideologies of
progress
consider indigenously so ritual
practices such as alcohol drinking
as backward and civilized and
uncivilized
these propagandas redefine a static
image of the lisu
and contribute to lisu cultural loss and
dignity loss
i show how non-christian alcohol
drinking men
refuse such ideologies
gathering to drink and play the men
infused melancholia with play humor
and laughter and keep supposedly bygone
practices
alive through the partial revitalization
of old alcohol drinking rituals
this analysis joins scholarly limitizing
eurocentric ideas about melancholia as
pathological
so the conventional idea the
conventional freudian idea that
melancholia is a incomplete grief a
grief that is
unhealthy because the morning can never
be concluded
situating lisu experiences of loss in
relation to historical colonialism
my analysis shows how the pathology lies
not in these relationships with laws
but in the colonial processes
undergirding laws
in this context melancholia is not
a passive inability to embrace change
but an active unwillingness to move on
the talk is organized into four parts i
will begin with a brief introduction
of the colonial dynamics animating the
ethnographic context in which i work
next i discuss alcohol within the triad
of lisu indigenous cultural paradigms
christianity and chinese development
following which
i delve into a night of drinking a
melancholic play
with a group of non-christian alcohol
drinking men
and finally i close this talk with a
brief discussion
on listening to affliction and the
implications
of such forms of listening for public
health interventions
so i'm going to begin with a brief
discussion on the ethnographic context
to set the scene
the lisu are an indigenous people living
dispersed across the highlands of
mainland southeast asia
along the borders of china myanmar
thailand and india
my ethnography focuses on the lisu in
the new river valley
on the china myanmar border as you can
see the
the river follows the blue line there
the valley is formally within the
borders of the chinese state
but geographically located in the
highlands of mainland southeast asia
a region referred to by some scholars as
domia
scholars have defined zomia as a vast
fluid zone
where communities have historically fled
to escape state rule
the lisu are one of the many indigenous
communities residing in this transporter
terrain
the new river valley is the traditional
territory of many indigenous peoples
with the lisu constituting one of the
largest communities
like many countries in asia china does
not recognize the existence of
indigenous groups within its borders
the li-su are classified by the chinese
communist government
as one of the officially recognized 55
ethnic minorities
but the lesson experience of cultural
erasure
and political marginalization under
chinese assimilationist ethnic policies
resonates with the struggles of
indigenous communities elsewhere
as alfred and con tassel argue it is the
oppositional
place place-based existence along with
the consciousness of being in struggle
against the dispossessing and demeaning
fact of colonization
by foreign peoples that fundamentally
distinguishes
indigenous peoples from other peoples of
the world
this article connects the lisu's
struggle with the experiences of
indigenous communities elsewhere
to relativize chinese ethnic
classifications
to underscore the psychic and cultural
experience
of being lisa
like other indigenous communities
residing in this transporter highland
region
the lisu wrestle with multiple colonial
forces
including state civilizational projects
economic
development and region and religious
missionarization
these processes have estranged lisu from
their traditional ritual practices
which they call practices of the earlier
days
these include making offerings to the
spirits niti
soul calling haku spirit dancing niki
and sorcery nisha and resemble those
carried out by other indigenous
communities in the region
when i began my dissertation fieldwork
in 2015
i came eager to learn about lease to
ritual life
but many of my lisu interlocutors
treated my questions
about rituals as inquiries about the
past
they explained that these rituals which
often involved alcohol
were pre-christian practices that were
no longer
being followed as with many
christianized indigenous communities
the introduction of christianity
effectively divided
history into two distinct parts
pre-christianity
and post-christianity
today the majority of lisu in the valley
practiced
indigenized protestant
all christian activities must be
endorsed by the central church
which is part of the state sanctioned
three self-protestant church
although some needs to practice
alternative non-state-sanctioned
forms of christianity they are actively
persecuted by the chinese communist
party and have become a minority
despite government surveillance of
christian activities
many christian leads to continue to
relate to christianity
as something beyond full government
control
christianity remains an important source
of power
healing and resistance against chinese
state hegemony
but dominant leads to christian ideology
also have many structural parallels with
chinese ideologies of development
including a linear notion of time and
progress
christian needs to reproduce chinese
domination in many ways
for example lisu christian's linear
conception of time and progress
didn't denigrate non-christians as
primitive demon worshipers
although many leso christian practices
are similar to traditional rituals
christian leads to work hard to
differentiate themselves from
non-christians lisu christianity forbids
smoking gambling telling non-christian
once upon a time origin stoning stories
anima
tatsuyami and above all drinking alcohol
many christians who hesitate even to
share memories of traditional
cosmologies and rituals
for fear of being labeled unfaithful and
being ostracized by the christian
community
certainly christian lisu have a complex
and contextual relationship with
non-christian leasure practices
and people but a defining characteristic
of many christian nisu
is the constant cultural work they do to
distance themselves
from their supposedly sinful
non-christian leisure paths
the rise of christianity has occurred
alongside rapid chinese
development like many ethnic communities
in contemporary china
lisu have negotiated with the civilizing
mission of encroaching chinese state
power for centuries
in the communist era rapid chinese
development has further appended the
ways of life of the nisu and other
minorities
with accelerating upheaval since the
2000s
like christianity chinese development
discourses
deny the co-evilness of lisu indigenous
life worlds
while christianity is recognized by many
lesson and chinese people
as a modern foreign religion lisu
indigenous ritual practices are labeled
as primitive
many lisu have internalized this
ideology of contempt
through residential schooling factory
work
and urbanization misu are being
recruited into the chinese state
bureaucracy
market economy and high majority society
these assimilationist programs have
gained intensity in recent years
since 2000 since 2011 chinese ethnic
policies have adopted a fiercer
assimilationist stance towards its
ethnic minority populations
in this context the arenas in which
minority ways of life
can be recognized have narrowed to the
domains of tourism
or ethnological research that is lisu
traditional practices
are being petrified into static objects
for tourists and research consumption
lisua thus
simultaneously being assimilated into
the dominant chinese society
and being objectified into artifacts
so my next section talks about alcohol
and how alcohol works within this
context
i i titled this the gift of alcohol and
it's the gifts from the ancestors
alcohol lies at the center of the
triadic relationship between
these two indigenous cultural paradigms
christianity
and chinese development once a sacred
item
used during important rituals alcohol
was respected
as a powerful substance by the lisu
traditionally among many lisu alcohol
was seen as a gift
from the spirits a powerful medium that
connects
humans to non-humans and transforms
sadness to joy accepting the gift of
alcohol
binds the least person to a reciprocal
relationship with the spirits
lisu sorcerers nipah were people who
knew how to wield the power of alcohol
to communicate with spirits
my little interlocutors described how
sorcerers used
alcohol as means to summon the spirits
with the aid of the assembled spirits
these sorceress could
deserving punishment and sought justice
for those who were wronged
alcohol was used in healing rituals for
example
it was also used in feeling rituals for
example
if a soul left the body after a
frightening encounter
skillful sorcerers could sometimes
reunite the lost souls
with their host bodies through
alcohol-mediated rituals
but for those who are less skillful
alcohol could be overpowering it could
deceive
if a person was unable to control the
voices of the spirits
alcohol consumption could lead to
temporary or permanent madness
nimei or spirit-induced epilepsy nitrite
out of respect for the powerful spirits
these who submit offerings of alcohol
and meat to the spirits
to honor their reciprocal ties
but as indigenous lisu ritual paradigms
and practices eroded with conversion to
christianity
under chinese development so did the
status of alcohol
the sacred relationship with alcohol has
changed significantly with development
and conversion to christianity
alcohol is now rejected by christians as
a poison
that tempts and contaminates the
speech of drunk men are the words of the
demons
within them rather than the human
animating the body
the alcohol drinkers are no longer seen
as skillful sorcerers
but as useless drunkards or worse yet
satan's underlings christian lisu
instead
accept another kind of gift leshri
the gift of eternal life
from god usa embracing god's grace
they seek to break away from their
supposedly demonic past
which alcohol recalls similarly
chinese development discourses often
portray minority people
like de lisu as people who drink too
much and who are ungrateful
under chinese and christian ideologies
of progress
alcohol drinking lisu are reified as
primitive
or damaged people and their spirits and
the spirits they mingle with
are branded as demonic or dismissed as
superstitious delusions
hypocritically the han majority sees
mainstream drinking in han society
as masculine virulent productive and
civilized
these days alcohol drinking lisu men and
women are stigmatized by christian and
chinese discourses
that often portray them as primitive
sexually loose
poor smelly and dirty these discourses
are gendered
although many lisa women drink men are
usually the heavy drinkers
alcohol drinking men jupiter has become
a general term
often used derogatorily i'm very happy
to talk more about the gender dynamics
uh in the q a
um this talk focuses and my book in my
book in progress generally focuses on
men
but i actually spend most of my time
with women
but contrary to popular and christian
beliefs alcohol dependency and
alcohol-related violence
emerge relatively recently traditionally
lisu alcohol
is made from maize because maize is an
important staple food for humans and
animals
in former times only social elites with
an abundance of maize
had the resources to make alcohol
the expansion of commercial alcohol
transformed these relationships with it
as commercial beer and liquor became
widely and cheaply available
in stores and rooms like commissaries in
the 1980s and 1990s
addiction has become more common among
nissu
the collapse of indigenous lisu cultural
practices
under christianization and chinese
development
has also disrupted the ritual context
that provides structure for lisu
drinking activities
the non-christian alcohol drinking men's
attachment to alcohol
takes place within this complex
historical landscape
by the time i visited ghosa most elders
in the village identified as christians
the alcohol drinking men whom i spent
time with were the few
elders in the village who remain
non-christians
there were about a dozen of them a
handful were particularly close
anka zoda and his best friend uncle moby
uncle sappo and his two brothers
ankasati and angkosaki
and the younger uncle yosa and anka aki
so following lisu attacker i'm using
these kinship terms such as uncle
awo and anti-mayo to index
intergenerational respect regardless of
formal kinship ties they proudly
proclaimed themselves
to be alcohol drinking men except for a
couple of their wives
most of the women in the village were
christians
although christian villagers were
generally unamicable terms
with the non-christian elders the
tension between the groups
were obvious during my field work
these men drank regularly some
like uncle zoda and uncle mobi drank as
often and as much as they could
others drank frequently but with more
control
angkasapo and his brothers ankasati and
agasaki
for example who usually brings drink
once or twice a month
for several days and then spend the rest
of the month relatively sober
this cyclical binge drinking resembled
the old drinking pattern
that anti-iona said was common in the
earlier days
when men used to drink for big
celebrations or for important rituals
the habits of the men were partly shaped
by their own personal histories and
circumstances
for example anka zoda's compulsive
drinking resulted in part
from the chronic pain he suffered from
having endured for sterilization under
china's birth planning policy
in the 1990s his son's frequent ventures
to drink away from home
with his friends was in turn probably
related to his father's rowdy drinking
gatherings at home
which drove the sun to find other venues
of release
in general older drinkers tended to
enjoy
liquor while younger drinkers like uncle
zoda's son
liked beer but older young all these
alcohol drinkers i met in kosa and
beyond preferred homemade liquor
and beer
during my stay in kosa i lived with
uncle zoda and aunty yonah
who had two children a son and a
daughter
uncle zoda and his son were not
christian auntie yonah
on the other hand was a devout christian
the daughter nana was a christian by
default
because of her gender and because of her
mother's faith
nana was my classmate and my leso
language tutor in minzu university
in the provincial capital of kane where
i was enrolled as a lisu language
student
like many younger members of the village
nana and her brother were usually away
nana was attending university and her
brother was working in the factories in
the cities the absence meant
that
i tilled the fields planted maize weeded
the grounds
scavenged for pig feed and cut firewood
alongside aunty jonah
through these everyday work activities
anti-ioanna taught me lisu
as i gained facility in lisu i conducted
most of my research
in the language of my host
although this paper focuses on these two
men i spent most of my days in the
village with lisa women
so this is um the women are uh
we're preparing the vegetables to sell
in the marketplace the next day and
i think this was already midnight by
then
for many of the women alcohol drinking
husbands were the heaviest burden
as the men parted through the night the
woman dealt with the everyday mundane
realities like for example
getting the vegetables prepared in
midnight to
sell in the market day i did not
participate in drinking alcohol
but i was often included as an observer
and a welcome photographer
during these rowdy gatherings i was
frankly
often tired from working in the fields
and i wish i could rest
instead of attending to the men's
reveries aunty yonah was exhausted as
well
yet i always felt there was a shared
understanding between auntie jonah and
the men
as if their drinking was also a
catharsis for her
although she did not drink she joined
them as they joke
and make fun of each other following her
example
i began to listen more carefully to the
drunken speech
of the alcohol drinking ban in kosa
village
so now i'm moving on to the next section
where i'm going to be talking about
melancholic play
in the night of drinking with the men
one ordinary wintry evening not long
after the pigs were fed
and the chicken feet prepared a group of
men came to visit uncle zodak
heavy footsteps on the bamboo porch
alerted us
to their arrival it was the usual
entourage
uncle moby the man condemned by an old
curse
uncle sappo the retired sorcerer in the
village
angkor api the villager afflicted with
epilepsy
anga yosa the divorcee who was captured
by burmese soldiers and presumed it for
seven years
and anka aki the widower whose wife went
mad
these were angkozoda's blood brothers
fellow non-christian men
who found solidarity with each other in
their shared love
for alcohol and the past andy yonah
welcomed them
she served them food which they declined
and shared unkazoda's alcohol with them
which they eagerly accepted the men had
gathered
to celebrate the return of uncle aki
akie was the youngest of the lot and
often left the village for long periods
of work in construction jobs in the
northern top in the northern part of the
county
actually it was a northern county above
the prefecture
passing bottle after bottle and cup
after cup
of alcohol the men chatted
laughed sang and cried in joy drink
alcohol uncle zodak cried let's talk
and joke together but no fighting no
quarreling
uncle sappo the eldest of them said
alcohol circulated continuously among
them
the gathering began relatively calmly
but rose quickly to a crescendo of
inebriated chaos
loud laughter howls reverberated through
the room
these support music videos blasted from
zoda's television
providing the shrill accompaniment to
this carnivalesque
scene the incandescent bulb that hung
above the flashing tv
and the burning flame from the campfire
caused moving shadows around the room
giving the strange effect that the house
was
even darker than it already was
excited by my camera the men insisted i
take pictures of them
drunk and half naked zoda sharing beer
with moby in a bowl
aki pretending to be a corpse hanging
from a tree
and me pretending to share a cigarette
with aki
each of these acts was a reference to
the past
zoda and moby sharing a beer from the
same bowl
resembled the cross cupping practice
that lisa used to perform during
weddings and other celebrations
uncle aki pretending to be a corpse
reminded me of the lisu story about
the star-crossed lovers who hanged
themselves from a tree
the cigarettes were new but they
represented
the traditional pipes that lisu used to
smoke
in their drunkenness the men broadcast
their skewed imaginings of the past
a liquid mix of half-memories false
memories
and incomplete erroneous stories about
things
people and events that may never have
actually been
i am a prophet uncle zorda called out
provoking much laughter among the men
bring me meat many of the sorcerers who
converted to christianity
became christian prophets uncle enjoyed
making fun of these
sorcerer prophets he saw them as
sorcerers trying to cheat their way into
the christians hearts and pockets
their true aim he said was to earn as
much meat as possible
tell me the next lottery number uncle i
joke with him
so that took a pause as he's trying to
find the number with his mind's eye
i don't see them so that replied
come back tomorrow the laughter
reverberated
the boundaries between the living and
the undead blurred
the more the men drank the closer the
spirits came to them
as the men descended into alcohol
madness jupiter
speech indicated the possible presence
of something
other than human
take a picture take a picture i am a
demon here to kill humans
i am a demon here to eat humans
shouted an alcohol mad uncle moby as he
insisted
that i take a picture of him and zoda
pretending he was holding aliso machete
moby stood behind zoda
acting like a demon about to kill an
oblivious zoda
the alcohol mad moby readied himself to
conduct an imaginary murder
possessed by the spirit moby was no
longer fully present
as was common on such occasions the
absent moby
wanted a lasting trace of his demon self
my nikon camera with its ability to
capture his absent presence
became an object of desire
in zoda's house spirit and men
rendezvoused
like the stigmatized men who summoned
them the spirits
were beings denied recognition formerly
powerful and respected spirits they had
turned
into downtrodden forgotten and dismissed
demons
wronged by the circumstances of their
life and death
wronged by the christians who betrayed
them and wronged by the chinese state
that branded them as
primitive superstitions the demonized
spirits
were unable to rest identifying with
these demons
the men let the spirit speak allowing
them
to express the shared grievances of men
and spirit
in their drunkenness the men took on the
dual role
of the sorcerer seeking justice and the
demon
wronged by others rather than trying to
free themselves from the spirits
they summoned them to the present their
melancholic howls
pierced the silence of the village night
jolting their christian neighbors awake
making them listen to the sounds and
sorrows
of banished ancestors
as the night went on the men descended
deeper
and deeper into alcohol madness hurling
insults
at each other they crooned out of tune
music
and gave indecipherable speeches about
themselves
and their past among the men
moby and zoda were the most resilient
drinkers
as everyone began to wander home moby
stayed with zoda
the two egged each other on to drink
more
and play harder the next morning
sleep deprived andeona and i found them
both unconscious
moby lay next to the dead campfire on
the floor
soda was sprawled on his bed motionless
in the dead of the night when others
sleep the men
called upon the spirits with the alcohol
together
men and spirit danced sang and haunted
the quiet orderly lives of their
christian neighbors
drinking alcohol the men's bodies became
the medium
through which spirits re-entered the
world of the living
dancing and singing together spirit and
men
honored their ties to each other their
despair
of loss was transfigured into the joys
of existence
forgotten memories into living rituals
demons into ancestors
alcohol drinking men into powerful
sorcerers
and death back into life
drinking is an act of togetherness
alcohol brought together the alcohol
drinking men in kosa
as brothers with a shared commitment to
remem to remembering lost practices
and forgotten ancestors
whereas the christians in the village
sought to break away
from old practices the alcohol-drinking
men
refused to move on their melancholia
united them as a community against the
christian majority
in the village we
are the alcohol drinking men we work
when we feel like working
stop when we feel like stopping not like
those people who go to church
they are full of superstitions uncle
saki
proudly proclaimed once turning a
typical christian insult back at the
christians themselves
the men purposefully went against those
things that christians said and did
christians attended church and did not
work on sundays
non-christians had alcohol drinking
gatherings and worked
any day of the week or not work
christians did not eat the blood and
internal organs of animals
alcohol drinking men on the other hand
priced them
as delicacies christians considered
phrases such as
thank you shamu forgive me gagaley
and how are you polite non-christians
found these expressions phony the
alcohol drinking uncles
in zukosa enjoyed poking fun at the
christians
the best time to steal meat is when
christians are saying grace before a
meal
when they have their eyes shut pick your
favorite pieces of meat from the dishes
they won't even notice and if they do
you can just
call them out for not praying properly
uncle moby
uncle zoda's best friends taught me once
the men's witticism expanded beyond
making fun of their christian neighbors
the big jokes about cunningham chinese
migrants
strange foreigners book smart but
otherwise stupid university students
bewitching burmese women lying christian
missionaries
and greedy chinese communist officials
once the government distributed each
household some walnut cuttings to plants
although walnuts are lucrative many
leaves to avoid eating them
eating too much walnut oil they say can
turn
a person into an idiot xi jinping must
like eating a lot of walnuts
that's why he keeps asking us to plant
walnuts no wonder he's so stupid
uncle zoda said as we planted walnut
cuttings
as the men passed alcohol around they
reversed chinese and christian
discourses of gratitude
they were no longer the ungrateful ones
for rejecting the gifts of christianity
and development
it was instead the christians who were
ungrateful
having forgotten about the spirits
having abandoned their brothers and
sisters
and having ultimately given up what it
means
to be lisa
breathing new life to old reciprocal
ties
the men rebuilt a community from ruins
from the ruins of loss and reminded
their fellow villagers
christians and non-christians alike that
they were not yet dead
as uncle moby used to defiantly yell i
cannot die
shrimada refusing to let go
the men held on together to fragments
of what it means to be lisu outside
of christian and chinese civilizational
frames
so i'm now going to conclude
around two years after i left gosa i
received a message from nana
letting me know that her father
angkozoda was critically ill
his organs were failing and he was dying
upon receiving the news of uncle's
illness i prepared my return to china
but as i was getting ready to go back
covet 19
hit wuhan and travels to china soon
became impossible
gosav village went under lockdown
villagers were instructed to remain
in their own homes and villages i call
uncle zoda one afternoon
aware that it might be our last
conversation
i'm still here he said almost cheerfully
not dead yet these days we cannot go
anywhere
even the demons cannot move if demons
don't move
people can't move on either i'm just
hanging out
watching tv sitting by the fire next to
the demons
not dead yet he burst into laughter
i laughed with him zoda continued to
play in the face of death
melancholia once more transformed
into a half funny joke
this talk has examined how low status
lisu alcohol-drinking men play with
melancholy
as an act of refusal within communities
struggling for their cultural
and spiritual survival like
playing with melancholia can be a mode
of refusal
as i have argued the alcohol drinking
men's melancholia
is a refusal because it is constituted
by a playful unwillingness to let go
rather than an inability to overcome
by the same token their refusal is
melancholic
because it is characterized by an
attachment
to things that are supposed to be dead
infusing grief with play humor
and joy the men draw on despair
loss and suffering as a cultural
resource
for the reconstitution of community
within
but apart from the dominant christian
and chinese frames of civilization
ambivalently mixing sadness and joy
tragedy and comedy forgetting and
remembering
their melancholic play illustrates the
complex contradictions
constituting experiences of grief that
shape
intimate everyday politics
refusal through melancholic play speaks
to cross-cultural experiences
of how people recuperate and regenerate
in the throes of colonial
domination indigenous and minority
communities
are often portrayed as damaged victims
while there is no doubt that these
communities struggle with great
injustice and oppression
people face suffering not only with
anger and despair
but also with humor and play illness and
afflictions
such as alcohol dependency are symptoms
of victimhood
but they are also acts through which
people
convey communicate and share their
experiences
by attending to jokes and social
histories of men
who might be considered by public health
experts as
alcoholic i pay attention to the social
commentaries
and historical memories they articulate
through their affliction situating such
afflictions
as alcohol dependency in relation to
these historical structures
reverses the disease discourse
the pathology lies not in the sick
person
but in the social and political
structures within that illness emerge
within which their illness emerge
liso alcohol drinking men's melancholic
refusal
provides inspiration for thinking about
how to combine
dark anthropology and the anthropology
of the good
proponents of the anthropology of the
good critique
contemporary anthropology's tendency to
universalize the suffering
subject which they argue is a modern day
representative replacement
of the savage slot similarly
indigenous scholars have proposed a
moratorium on damage-centered research
that portrays
indigenous communities as only or mainly
damaged
but this call to suspend damage-centered
research
is not about denying damage nor about
turning our attention towards
only the good rather it is a call for an
epistemological shift
in the way research is conducted and
motivated
activist anthropology in which
anthropologists are directly involved in
the social movements they study
provides an important starting point for
rethinking the
theories of change undergirding research
part of this epistemological shift
towards research for change and
transformation
is to recognize people as complex
subjects with shifting and contradictory
desires
desires that simultaneously resist and
reproduce
power lee su men's melancho
melancholic alcohol drinking is
constituted by such
complex interplays between despair and
joy
and between loss and regeneration their
melancholia
is not just an embodiment of victimhood
but also
the grounds on which they refuse
colonialism
and celebrate their survival theories of
the subject
that fully recognize such complex and
contradictory desires
from critic form a critical foundation
for building solidarities
and for rethinking the theories of
change undergirding
anthropological research thank you
i looks very excited about your
questions thank you
thank you ting for a fantastic talk um
so we have plenty of time for question
and answer but i want i'm mindful of
people's time i know some people have to
leave it one sometimes because of
various time commitments so i'd like to
ask anyone who thinks they need to leave
by one
please ask your question first otherwise
we'll just go in the order in which i
see hand so if you want to say
that you need to ask first put it in the
chat
otherwise we'll just go in an order
is there anyone who who has a time
commitment
otherwise i'll just call on al
because i see al has a question um
so i'll go ahead and ask your question
and if anyone else needs to we'll follow
up with that
hi um nice to meet you i'm a phd student
here in anthropology and environmental
studies i used to be at yale and us
so this is great um and no so this is
fascinating and if this is a chapter i'm
looking forward to the book i'm so i'm
really excited um
and i particularly was thinking about
the ways that this is similar or
different to
like parts of northern thailand where
you have the koran kachin and burma as
well
and how the christian buddhist narrative
is actually fundamentally very different
um
so that was kind of interesting for me
to think through and compare because um
to the christians in the village in
northern ireland they were like oh um
um we're super open to christians the
buddhists we're like the dominant people
and
it's all it's all great so it's really
interesting the very clear um
reversal there um in terms of what i'm
familiar with but sorry my question
was about ontology um and i'm wondering
how you theorize ontology in a sense so
in the
in in one primary sense there's that
freudian uncanny then what's interesting
here is i feel like the melancholia kind
of
comes into that kind of lack of
inability to kind of do away with
repression so that coming back with the
repression
um and it's really interesting and also
to think about the role of the spirits
then
in terms of them being wrong um but then
kind of andrew johnson's book talked a
lot more about ambivalence so here the
spirit seems to be a lot more active and
angry
as opposed to like a more ambivalent
kind of relationship um
on the on the river and and in the sec
another sense of ontology is this kind
of
social control um and and so this idea
about
nations being built on the zone of mass
death is something like 45 talks about
in china and
i'm wondering how to what extent you can
think about ontology as
molding kind of individual and and and
what you're talking about in
intra leads to identity but also kind of
different scales of identity in the kind
of social control there
so i'm just wondering kind of like how
you're thinking about there's so much
through the ethnography that
that's coming through i'm just wondering
like how um how you're putting all those
together
thank you um so i'll just respond or do
it
um that's such a great question
um and i don't know if i can answer
completely do it justice
um um
so i think the way i'm thinking about
haunting is partly that
indeed there is this desire to move away
that we have overcome our indigenous
or our kind of uh either it is the
sinful past from the christian
perspective
or it is um that we are we're moving on
from the backward leads to practices and
we're trying to
become modern but that is never a
complete um
complete conversion in a sense so the
uncanny it is like an unkind reminder
that these men are living in this space
they are staying in this space
that refines um the villagers and the
people around them
that you have never really actually
you're not really
ever completely uh modern um and
and actually um the
uh demons reside within you um and so
that's perhaps that haunting emerges
um in that in that sense um
and in the sense uh in this in the scale
of uh i thought that was so interesting
the nation built on mass death because
i think this is the place that is built
on mass death
and so there is that scale that's really
helpful for me to think through and
and include in my next iteration of this
chapter because
there is that scale of the village
haunting the men haunting the villagers
by reminding them of the past
but there's also the scale in which this
whole place
which has been which is being promoted
as a tourist hot spot
as developed because a chinese state is
developing this place it's modern it's
becoming modern there's no more poverty
um but all that narrative
is built on so much death in the region
cultural death the cultural
death of the men um that i've described
but also the physical
death of the people who are dying in
traffic accidents who are dying in
construction work who are dying in
landslides
who are dying because of family problems
and suicide and mental health and
alcoholism and sickness and cancer and
other kinds of new diseases that were
never there in the first place
but have recently become for some reason
like other parts of the world
development is correlated with
the rise of all these non-communicable
diseases and so there is that level at
the level of that scale that you're
talking about where development
is actually built on mass death and and
in the sense um
this place is is a haunted by that that
death that is also being repressed
by the discourse of development and
that's really helpful
um and i think there's a third level of
haunting where
i'm trying to think about which is
almost to br get out the question of
trying to bracket out the question of
the demons and whether i can't even
understand
what they are doing um and and there's a
part of the
the chapter that um i'm i i wasn't able
to include
because of time um where um
uncle moby passes away uh but he returns
in the form of dreams
and uh spirits um and it's almost like
he continues to refuse to die
even after death and so there's that
that's that openness
that um that i'm not sure if i want to
allow for a closure
to analyze what's actually happening
there um what is uncle moby actually
coming back or is this like an uncanny
thing but
i think i'm trying to see how his death
actually created this ripple
effect and um regenerates a lot of
discourse
around haunting um that i am not quite
sure
i i should um maybe i should refuse to
theorize it to
to too rigorously
so maybe allowing the ethnography to to
haunt itself a bit i guess i don't know
thank you thank you for the great
question thank you ting um
does anyone have a question i have
several questions but i'm mindful i want
to make sure other people have the
chance to ask but if
if there's not one at the moment i will
i'll i will ask one first
and then follow up later um
so ting this is fantastic talk very
interesting um there's a lot of
directions to go that i'm interested in
but i want to talk a little bit about
sort of the micro politics and spatial
organization of these places
in in the valley where you were working
in the villages um
i'm curious if you're doing this kind of
research
and there's such a kind of negative
stereotype
of the alcohol drinking lesu men among
the christian
uh lisu um when you fall into a group of
men doing field work right
or or families that have men of this
nature um does that end up precluding
the possibility of working with
christians
and or or how does that make getting
negotiated and that raised my other
question sort of just ethnographic
description a little bit
um about the christianity in the area
and the spatial organization of villages
like are there sort of like
spatial arrangements and where you know
these men
live in a separate part or even sort of
on the outskirts outside
or anything like that or forms of
exclusion
um and also in terms of the actual
christian
conversion process um are people born
christian or do they convert and the
reason i ask that is because
some of what you're describing you know
when in
american 12-step programs and all these
things there's a lot of literature
that shows the parallel to conversion
and there's a lot of christian language
in those processes
and sometimes when i was listening to i
was thinking well the way in which some
of the christians are responding to the
alcoholism sounds kind of similar to
like the way a 12 a member of a 12-step
program might speak of it
and so that made me wonder if some of
the christians themselves
had been former drinkers and and this
kind of reaction to it is
based on these kinds of dynamics so
there's a lot in there but
mainly i want to hear a little bit more
about the micro relations of christians
and non-christians
and also how that affected you as a
field worker
thank you eric um yeah the
the micro politics were complicated to
navigate
um so uh
actually i think it was the other way
around um
that when i first started working i
worked a lot with christians or i
i i i my first
visit to the nuclear valley was working
with christian missionaries
and i felt that during those early
visits
often times i was precluded from talking
with
non-christians or they were like don't
talk to them or the christians would
move away and i as i would follow the
christians
and even though i was actually very
curious to talk to the non-christians
and at times i think earlier on i think
i was biased by
um uh some christian perceptions as well
often thinking oh these uh people
um they are why don't they not drink so
so um i think it took a lot of my own
having to uh interrogate those
assumptions as well which were the
assumptions of the people
that i was working with from at the
beginning
and so so it took years to kind of like
then build relationships with the
christian communities
um and um and then uh
work with non-christians and and still
like have that trust with the christians
that i'm
um i'm not an alcohol drinker
and so i think that was actually this
was actually something i was thinking
today
that um i it was easier for me
to be i wonder how it would have been
like if i had gone to the field and just
been really stubborn and said i drink
alcohol
and i'm not christian and i'm just going
to hang out with
the non-christians but i did not that
was not my starting point the starting
point was
um i'll go to church i'll do the rituals
with you
i'm not christian but i will um i will
follow the
steps and and be included in in your
conversation and be willing to listen
and learn about
uh the bible um and then that that
that starting point then allowed me the
non-christians allowed me to talk to
them
uh but i i think if it was the other way
around that if i started as a
non-christian i'm not so sure
the christian communities would be so
welcome uh welcoming
to me um so so because i started
with the christian communities then it
was difficult to
to get out into talking to the
non-christians uh because there were
lots of gatekeeping
uh but but the non-christians were
welcoming uh and were willing to talk
and ultimately
uh after a lot of kind of negotiation it
was it was
it was fine um
although i think because i was living in
a in a household where the the women
were christian
um so in that sense i i had to respect
the women and and
and also navigate being open to
hanging out with the men but also uh
respecting auntie
for wanting to she wanted to go to
church and to
um not drink alcohol with the men
the villages um
so all these micro politics play out in
very ritualistic ways as well
so even though the villagers in everyday
ways they
they kind of do get along with each
other um but
uh they they don't need um christian
christians don't eat the meat of
non-christians so if the non-christian
had a funeral or um
a family member and the non-christians
also had a funeral um
or a wedding the christians cannot
consume the eat
meat of the the the non-christian
so even though in an everyday way uh
people kind of get along with each other
um
in the kind of structural way or in the
virtual setting
this these boundaries are very clearly
drawn
and um and in the kind of backstage
um the conversations do take place where
the christians are critiquing the
non-christians and then the
non-christians are critiquing
the christians and i think um
being with a uh christian um
friend auntie jonah i think it was
possible to listen to both sides and so
that was
uh that was auntie and i'm
being open-minded be with both groups um
and allowing
allowing allowing conversations to take
place in between the groups
the oh i can go on about the micro
politics because it also affects kind of
uh the village
dynamics uh so the village has a whole
hierarchy system and then the men have
their own hierarchy system
so when the men were conducting uh work
parties they will follow their own set
their own hierarchies of who are the
seniors and the christians who follow
some of the other hierarchies and so
it's almost like they have two different
bubbles but intersecting
the spatial arrangements um
yeah that's really interesting because i
did not think about it but in fact it is
so true that
the christians tend to be the
non-christians tend to be living away
from the christians further out um and
um the where the non-christians were
living within the people tend to
consider they were near haunted
sites um i did not consider that that
was
connected directly to um alcohol
drinking
but um it i think there is some sort of
connection so um
that the people often cons like their
pathways that
go towards a non-christian's household
and there will be a haunted site or
there's
uh a kind of tombs around the
places where the non-christians reside
but this whole arrangement now is i
understand it's completely
changed since i was last able to visit
because
of the one belt one road initiative
which runs through the village
and so all the villagers who were living
by the roads i had to move up into
the villages into the mountains i wasn't
working
deep into the mountains but somewhere in
the middle um and so
um so now all the spatial arrangements
um are are messed up
and auntie you and i was saying next
time i come back i won't be able to
recognize
people's houses because everybody's
living next to each other
um it's very crowded now that's what i
sense and the 12-step thing is so
accurate i
that's so great thank you yes a lot of
the men
were alcohol drinkers and in that sense
there's a haunting there as well because
they're haunted by i guess the desire
and so there's a very strong kind of we
are we're going to reject the alcohol
drinkers but
most of the villagers were alcohol
drinkers and it's only in the last 20
years
that this christianity has picked up in
this particular village
thanks ting while we're on this topic
there's two brief statements
or questions in the chat from larry
hashman and jared
bateman or biteman i'm not sure how to
pronounce that but um
you can you read those yourself or would
you like them to read it or
oh i can i can't read it um okay
larry is asking about whether the men
were surprised
uh i was a woman and interested in their
drinking
um there were alcohol drinking women
in the village a couple of their uncle
moby's wife
um was kind of a lapsing christian um
and aguiyousa's wife
was not a christian until until angkor
yosai eventually converted to
christianity and then she followed him
so women drinkers are not um
are not unheard of um
i felt that they were not so much
surprised
and i think it wasn't actually it was
kind of organic i didn't really started
off very interested i think i started
off very annoyed because i was like oh
why do i have to stay up and listen to
you drinking
um but then i think it took some time
for me
to to listen with auntie jonah
she's always so generous and and patient
um
and then i i think what they it was very
much a spectacle
um so it's very much kind of i want you
to see this i want you to take pictures
of me and and even
um got a bit angry when sometimes i was
so tired i didn't want to take pictures
anymore
um and so i think maybe not so much
maybe um
yeah maybe i think they they were not so
much surprised as
wanting to be heard i think it was
surprising for them that i wanted to
learn misu language
because it's always considered so i mean
why would you study lisu it's so useless
by the chinese government's kind of
propaganda but actually many of these
non-christianity men were not
as surprised as the christians about why
i wanted to learn this
for them it was that we have a lot of
skills we have a lot of knowledge why
wouldn't you want to learn from us it's
so strange that my kids don't want to
learn from me
um and so i think maybe
they are surprised that younger
generation people are not taking them
more seriously
does that answer the question
sorry i accidentally pressed the mute
button on youting so i didn't mean to do
that i was
meaning to press my own mute button
unmute myself but there was a quick
question
from jared and then there's a hand up
from william julian
um so if you get just go in that order
you'll have to unmute yourself because i
accidentally pressed your mute button
it's not your fault it's mine
thanks no no um my fault too i didn't
notice um
um yeah the meat prohibition is really
interesting
um ethnographically
um i i i think uh
ethnographically so um the idea is that
christians
are not allowed to eat um the meat of
non-christians because it will make them
sick
um it's it's kind of a betrayal of a
promise that you made to
god um and that you will be punished um
and and there were stories about men who
um
the one and the ones i'm thinking of are
all men um
and and um so the alcohol drinking men
who converted to christianity but then
uh um ate the meat of um
of a non-christian um died of
um some a tummy
problem he couldn't stop going to the
bathroom
and another one wasn't to do with um
christianity so much
and non-christianity was there was a
christian
who ate the meat of a um
of a wild animal and
actually it might not even to do with
i'm not so sure if the person was
christian but
the least dude person uh ate the meat of
a wild
animal a big wild animal and um
and while animals are supposed to have
spirits in them and that spirit
eventually killed
the leasu person so there are these
stories about meat
that that can be eaten and cannot be
eaten
um along the lines of christian and
along the lines of
lisa versus the spirits as well um
i think it's something to do
my my instinct is to think that it's
something to do with reciprocity
and um because one of the stories
is that uh lisu actually have an
agreement with the spirits
um to always be giving need to the
spirits
um if the nizu stops
providing meat to the spirits then
the least person will fall ill but it's
been many many
years since christians provide meat to
the spirits and so perhaps it's
something about
allegiances and betrayal um and um
and what and and the in the punishments
for for not meeting those reciprocal
ties
um i'm sorry does that answer a little
bit i think this is something that i'm
also working on and trying to
make sense off too
no that was a great reply thing
i wanted to i'm mindful of the time
everybody
although ting said that sometimes she
doesn't like staying up taking pictures
of people
i should remind everyone that it's 1am
over there
in singapore where she's uh dialing in
so i wondered if
um the next two julian i didn't mean to
make you disappear
um but oh sorry um
i was gonna say that julian and tui
could ask their questions at once
but that may have made julian disappear
i didn't mean it in that way but anyhow
tweet can you ask the last question
before we say goodbye
sorry it's too late there
it's night at 10 am here so it's perfect
yes i'm sorry for that
i listened to you to the
it reminds me about vietnam of the
mekong delta where i work is exactly the
same when i first came there
from ho chi minh city and so the men
drinking
and it's exactly the same so my question
is i have a lot of questions in mind but
we don't have time i just have
one question for now like the women's
attitudes
like based on my observation in the
medical delta
like 20 years ago when the economic
development
like women didn't go outside they stay
in the village
in the village and then they
enjoy the men's drinking sometimes they
complain that they enjoy
so through drinking men empower
themselves for drinking
and women enjoy it and women prepare
food for them
but encourage them to drinking like they
don't come in they didn't complain but
when economically
developed women went outside for for job
for job income they did they don't
like anymore so they so i don't i'm not
sure that's about vietnam they would
never make them better
so i'm not sure what happened there
based
in in the area where you research
like because you talk about development
in this cause and environmentation so
how that
influenced the women's attitude and the
mind men are
men stay the same i think in their
mechanism men still enjoy drinking but
women they chant
because of development that's my
question i have a lot more
thank you that's so interesting um
that's so interesting
um so after development they actually
stopped enjoying
the men drinking it's so interesting
um i think um
there's one in my f and where i'm
working i think um
uh the women in general if they are
christians they
they generally um that's they generally
really perform not liking
um men drinking but backstage
uh they do drink um kind of like on
special occasions and they have like
their special
alcohol beer um and then they'll be like
okay secret secret don't tell anybody
um and and i i take pleasure in that
because like i actually want to drink a
lot of times and um
so i i don't um i don't tell people
because i want to continue
drinking too um
so so then i think there was also this
incident that was very interesting
because i think i feel like auntie jonah
was kind of that way where she
really enjoyed hanging out with the men
drinking um
and actually there was a period of time
um and so did her daughter and a lot of
other women too they like
you know outwardly they really perform
how they don't like alcohol drinking men
but then when it comes to hanging out
with alcohol drinking men some of them
really seem to be
having a lot of fun with the men and in
fact when uncle zoda
stopped um stopped drinking for a while
because he was um he was
he was very um uh shocked by
uncle moby's death and really worried
about himself because the villagers
often say that death in the village i
work with come in pairs
so he was really worried about his life
and he stopped drinking for a while
and it was almost as if anti-iona was
very disappointed anti-ona and nana
seemed almost disappointed that he was
no longer drinking
so um so that's that's that i think
maybe it's similar
um but i haven't really come across how
women coming back and they don't like
men drinking but i feel like a lot of
time women come back and in fact they
they drink themselves um so
kind of the migration patterns change
the a lot of people become not christian
after they come back from migrating in
the in the cities
it's so interesting it changes
um i'd like to kind of gracefully bring
it to close but i'm mindful that there's
one last question from denny
about the experiences with women while
men are drinking so if you wanted to say
just a really quick reply to that
then i'll stop the recording and then we
can kind of
linger a little bit if anyone likes to
but i do want to bring it to
close since it's so late over there
yeah so um a very uh yeah so
mostly women um christian women
are working very hard um so
everyday chores taking care of the pigs
going to look for pig food looking for
firewood
even managing all the bureaucracy
because
chinese government often have to fill in
forms you have to go down to the village
brigade and
if you can't write you have to find
somebody who can write who
can communicate who can
got into fights and she had to deal with
that so uncle was often
um yeah just drinking and
um and she she would have to deal with
all that
and so it's very gendered and very
patriarchal and when he was drunk he
often
would even try to stop her from relaxing
um
so i mean yeah that's something i
i think it's um this is not
this is it is an affliction it's not
it's not uh easy for anybody to be in
that space
um i guess at the same time as trying
not to romanticize drinking
um i think it's also important to
to hear this other angle but i think it
is from the women's perspective it can
be
very frustrating um and uh from from a
christian woman like auntie unless
perspective who has to deal with so much
so much of the mundane everyday life
and it's so interesting it's so gender
that the men take to get to take the
spectacle the sport of the spectacle
whereas the women are in the mundane and
the boring
and i end up writing about the spectacle
rather than the mundane
so i yeah it's very interesting thank
you denis
well um thank you ting for a fantastic
talk i i hope everyone can join me
in thanking you for just this wonderful
presentation and
great q and a session as well thank you
johnson thank you for the great question
so helpful for me
really helpful